[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi.
Timothy Jordan, your
friendly developer advocate,
here at Google I/O 2017.
I'm in the machine
learning area,
and we're gonna check out
a lot of really cool stuff.
A reminder before I get to it.
If you'd like to see
any of this footage,
or any of the other Sandbox
tours that I've been doing,
go to g.co/io/guide.
First off, I'd like to check
out the Cloud TPU in person.
Wow.
So much heat sink.
MAGNUS: This look
like a skyscrapers.
It's like a miniature
city down there.
It's amazing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is
seriously one of the best Tron
moments I've had in years.
MAGNUS: This is among
the most amazing things
I've ever seen in my life.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, Magnus.
Everybody, this is Magnus.
You may know him from,
well, being Magnus,
and all sorts of things.
Hi, Magnus.
MAGNUS: Hi, how are you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm
doing super well.
So you've been hanging out with
all this really cool machine
learning stuff all day long.
MAGNUS: Yeah.
That's right.
We've been here all day
doing different machine
learning stuff.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'd like
to check out some of it,
and just play with it.
MAGNUS: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's
try AI Duets first.
So what is this?
MAGNUS: So you can actually
play on these things,
and then the network
generates something back.
Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So it's kind of like the
machine playing music with you.
MAGNUS: Yeah.
It's kind of constructing
music based on what you play.
It's trying to create something
similar, but still different.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK I
want to try it out.
MAGNUS: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
That's a lot of fun.
It feels a little
like that scene
in "Close Encounters
of the Third Kind."
MAGNUS: Yeah.
Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, so there's
one other thing
that I would like
to check out while we're here.
And that's the candy sorter.
MAGNUS: Yes.
It's an amazing thing.
It consists of so many different
machine learning technologies
in one single demo.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Should
we check it out?
MAGNUS: Yeah, for sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
As promised, we're
gonna check out
the candy sorter.
What is a candy
sorter, you may ask?
Well, Dave's here to
tell us what that is.
DAVE: OK, great.
So what we're gonna
show here is how
you can infuse machine
learning into your apps
without actually being
a data scientist.
And the way we're gonna
do it is through candy
and through labels.
Now, what we've done
is we've gone through,
we've trained a model up
in the cloud that for--
basically, we've taken
an existing model,
and we've trained it for candy.
So we've put labels,
and next to candies.
And we've got a
little camera here
that's taking
pictures of the candy.
And we put labels that have
been associated with the candy.
We sent it up to the Google
Cloud Machine Learning engine,
and we've trained the model,
we used the Inception V3 model,
and using transfer learning.
And so what we're
gonna show now is, now
that the model's been
trained, is actually
the serving of the model.
So I'm gonna take candy
here and just throw it out
in front of the camera.
And this is just
any random candy
that we have trained
this model for.
So I like gum.
I want to make sure there's
plenty of gum out there.
And you'll want to make sure
there's a little bit of space
in between there.
And again, when we train this,
this image, it has been--
it has been a
well-trained model that
has been modified with these
images and these labels.
You can even write your own
labels, which is awesome.
So now it's trained.
Now the fun part
of this is actually
the serving, the prediction.
So you're gonna
speak into this mike,
you're gonna hit this
little mike button here,
you're gonna speak
into this mike
and ask for some kind of candy.
And it's gonna make
a call to our API,
it's gonna understand the text--
it's gonna do a Speech API, so
speech-to-text
API, and then it's
gonna understand the
intent of what you're
asking for using our natural
language processing API,
and then it's going to
make a prediction based
upon the model that's
sitting out in the cloud.
And the best part
is, hopefully--
cross your fingers--
it's gonna give you-- it's gonna
pick-- make the prediction,
pick it, and then
give it to you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
OK.
DAVE: All right, so click on
that, and speak into the mike.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: May
I have some gum?
DAVE: So it understood what
you said, May I have some gum.
Now it's going through
natural language processing.
It's identifying the noun,
the noun there, and gum.
So now it's trying to--
it will then match, based
upon the model that's
been modified--
come on, come on, come on--
and it is picking chewing gum.
And there, the camera identified
Extra long-lasting watermelon
gum.
Now, the camera's-- the--
and over, and there's your gum.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's great.
DAVE: Machine
learning in and out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I
get to keep this, right?
DAVE: Yeah, actually, I've got
like seven boxes back there.
So please, everybody take one.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Dave, thanks so much.
DAVE: All right, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
was pretty great.
All right, so that is the
machine learning area.
I hope you've enjoyed these
experiences as much as I had.
It's really cool to see machine
learning up close and personal,
see how it can be used in
real life through these demos.
And I hope it inspires
you to do some cool stuff
with TensorFlow and with Cloud.
See you later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]